hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the last main topic that Immanuel Kant
addresses in his groundwork of the
metaphysics of morals is that of what he
called the limits of practical reason
now this word limits in German is
grenzen it can also mean something like
border and that might be useful for
thinking about what are the borders that
if it were to cross it would be
illegitimate it's on the right side over
here but if it goes over here it's sort
of out of bounds it's out of its element
it's no longer authorized you might
think and this is a fairly long
discussion I've got quite a bit of stuff
up here on the board but I'll also be
referring to the text in talking about
this and I think it might be a little
bit hard to grasp why this is
particularly important so we'll discuss
that toward the end so he begins by
talking about the will belonging to the
world of the understanding just earlier
he talked about this this is in
dialectic of reason and how we have to
see things both ways and how that's kind
of tricky and difficult and nonetheless
we have to do so and practical reason is
able to do that so that grasps the will
as a something that is ultimately coming
from our rationality as a way of
determining things it belongs to this
intelligible world not the world of
sense so he says that it's free from the
causality of the world of sense that is
if the will chooses not to be determined
in its actions by things like
inclinations desires appetites other
sorts of motives that are stemming from
the world of sense if it chooses in
another way of saying this not to follow
merely hypothetical imperatives then
it's actually free from the causality
that otherwise governs the entire
phenomenal world what Kant calls the
world of nature which would include
psychological and social laws as well so
how does it in fact determine itself
Kant insists over and over again that it
can determine itself in this
intelligible world and cause actions by
means of laws by means of laws that it
encounters that it gives itself and that
it thereby follows or you might even say
is not exactly what contents but if you
think about this actualizes out there in
the world of sense by by following those
laws now where do those laws come from
that's going to be a key issue before
that concept that within the world of
the understanding these laws apply
categorically to the will that means
that there are no exceptions there are
no hypotheses well if you're doing this
then this applies but you know if you're
not doing that then don't worry about it
these laws you know the for instance we
find the categorical imperative and its
formulations apply to the will if it
wants to be free if it wants to enact
its own freedom out there in its actions
in the world it must follow these these
laws that are provided to it by this
world of understanding which is the
world that we can get ourselves into
through thinking and this is the next
key point practical reason as you says
thinks itself into the world of
understanding it's not simply that the
world of understanding impinges upon it
or it experiences it or a revelation
comes down from on high this is
something that it does by clarifying its
own thought about what would be required
in order for morality really to exist
and to be actual and that we could go on
and on and on as we're thinking about
this we are not just thinking about that
as an object we are thinking about how
we fit in with that as thinking subjects
the very deep thought that Conte is
exploring here now he insists that that
practical reason which does have limits
legitimate limits and a good part of
critical
philosophy is in fact supplying those
limits and saying look up until this
point eh okay once you go over here
illegitimate and you're not doing
anything really philosophical or
something that's going to yield
knowledge rest so constant that does not
transcend its own limits when it is
thinking through this this intelligible
world it would however begin to
transgress those limits by doing certain
things so he says that you know reason
can overstep its limit if it were to
take the object of its will from that
intelligible world that the world of the
understanding right now what is kind
meaning by this cop thinks that we can
certainly get a categorical imperative
rule that applies to us from this world
as a matter of fact we are doing that as
we think about it as we work with it as
we make appeals to ourselves like hey
can you universalize that right that's
perfectly fine for practical reason to
do if it tries to claim that in this
intelligible world of which we don't
have empirical knowledge we somehow can
can lay out what all of the different
parts of it are then it would be going
beyond its proper limits it can't tells
us that the world of understanding we
must think of it as possessing its own
order and laws and that's fine but we
can't actually say that we know what
those are we can't reach that by some
sort of sensuous intuition we can't do
that by simply examining the
understanding reason simply scrutinizing
itself doesn't yield all of that content
instead what we get is a what he calls a
formal condition and that is you know
like the categorical imperative for
example the sorts of things that cat has
buttocks
this is why morality for Kant as
something that is coming you might say
substantively out of the intelligible
world is for us in our relation to the
sensible world in which we have to act
something that we can call formal so
that is one key limit for practical
reason it can indeed operate with this
this you know conception this idea you
know a number of ideas autonomy the
freedom of the will morality what that
one's principles are the categorical
imperative but it cannot go further than
that he also tells us that reason would
overstep all its bounds if it undertook
to explain how pure reason can be
practical
which would be exactly the same problem
as to explain how freedom is possible
now why is that the case
Kant says that when we explain things we
are reducing them as a bunch of
different particulars to general laws
and while we must assume that there are
laws governing this intelligible world
and as we said earlier in the text those
laws are actually providing the basis
for the laws of the sensible world we
don't know what those laws are except
for things like again the categorical
imperative we don't know the fullness of
them and so we we can't you might say
push back from practical reason into
pure reason which is doing speculative
or theoretical philosophy saying what is
the case so in some respects practical
reason can go further than pure reason
can but pure reason is almost you might
say the ideal at which we would love to
be aiming and reintegrating practical
reason into we can't do that because if
we do we we again transgress those
limitations we would overstep our bounds
so what does this mean he says that you
know freedom is a mere idea
the objective reality can't be shown
according to laws of nature it's not in
any possible experience and we can't
support it by any sort of example or
analogy it holds Good only as a
necessary hypothesis of reason in a
being that believes itself conscious of
having a will that is a faculty
different than mere desire as Kant says
something that we are able to use to
choose for ourselves following reason
the will and reason are intimately
connected for Kant now we we as human
beings of course do experience what he's
calling desire the Faculty of desire our
inclination all these things coming from
the sensible world and instead we can
choose to follow this will now can we
prove that we can't prove it by any sort
of empirical experiment nor can we you
know sort of tabulate up a bunch of data
and ultimately arrive at it and nor can
we do it just by some sort of inner
sense I feel that I have a free will or
something like that kind of it that
that's not helpful here it's something
that we must postulate it's something
that we cannot help but assume should we
you know want to think that there is
morality and that that's actually
possible and Khan thinks we can't help
but think that sooner or later if we
think about these matters so he goes on
he talks about this in another way of
saying that the subjective impossibility
of explaining the freedom of the will is
identical with another thing of
discovering and explaining an interest
which a human being can take in the
moral law not nevertheless we do
actually take interest in it because we
have some sort of effective experience
in relationship with Cantus calling
moral feeling right and he says that in
order that a rational being should we'll
what reason alone directs being they
ought to will it's no doubt useful that
there's some sort of connection between
the cognitive and the affective but
again we cannot actually say what that
consists in were we to do so again we
would be transgressing the laws or
they're not the laws the limits rather
of practical reason so there's a number
of things that we can in fact notice and
think without being able to provide some
sort of empirical proof that would
satisfy critics who rely solely upon
that can't say they're really missing
the boat they're not grasping that what
we're talking about is an intelligible
world we cannot also explore that
intelligible world in its entirety
according to Kant or we transgress those
limits so we see that these limits are
in some respect quite generous but in
other respects they might be viewed by
many people as rather frustrating Kant
thinks that he has in this work
discerned what those limits for us are
and those you know are you might say
boundaries beyond which we cannot cross
except under the pain of no longer being
philosophical or scientific or even
indeed moral so it's very important that
we at least from a theoretical
perspective which then turns into a
practical perspective understand
precisely what those limits are and that
is why he ends the work with that
discussion
you